à elles ont choqué ces images elles ont
choqué emmanuel macron alors même que
les personnels soignants des services de
réanimation alerter sur la gravité de la
situation nous avons aussi vu du monde
se rassembler dans les parcs des marchés
bondés des restaurants des bars qui
n'ont pas respecté la consigne de
fermeture elles ont choqué christophe
castaner il ya des gens qui pensent qu
ils sont des héros moderne à enfreindre
la règle elles vous ont choqué vous avez
été nombreux à nous le dire sur les
forums du figaro sur facebook
tout se résume cette indignation
notamment en une phrase les français
sont particulièrement indiscipline
indiscipline indisciplinés c'est votre
avis et on s'est dit sûr figaro live que
ça valait bien un débat problème comment
on fait quand on a plus l'équipe quand
on a plus de studios quand on a plus de
plateaux quand on est tous confinés
difficile de le faire en plateau comme
d'habitude mais rien n'interdisait de
demander aux invités de points de vue
aussi leur âge
[Musique]
indisciplinés les françaises je crois
que l'indiscipliné elle vient pas du
fait que les français soit foncièrement
indisciplinés ils sont latins comme le
sont les italiens mais quand on leur
donne des ordres clairs les français ils
obéissent et il sait ce qu'il faut faire
surtout si on est en temps de guerre
comme ça a été dit par le président de
la république
les français sont aussi plutôt impatient
et il ya un magnifique page de
tocqueville c'est la fin de l'ancien
régime et la révolution ou tocqueville
montre que les français sont un peuple
prêt à tout et hier son contraire c'est
et si les responsables de cette
prétendue indiscipline congénitale des
français est témoin les français eux
mêmes que leurs responsables sur ce
point nos trois débatteurs sont unanimes
nos trois débatteurs sont d'accord on
avait mené le maquereau qui le 7 mars
disait aux français de sortir d'aller au
théâtre de faire communier brigitte de
braver le virus et de vivre normalement
et puis qu'est-ce qu'il a fait le 15
mars est bien là dit aux français
d'aller voter parce que c'était
important de voter parce qu'il avait
maintenu le premier tour c'était son
choix personnel france on ne peut pas
tenir trop de propos contradictoires
on l'avait vu mon des élections
municipales restez chez vous mais
sortait quand même
en fait nos débatteurs trouve al'inverse
que les sondages le montrent d'ailleurs
les français ont plutôt joué le jeu à
quelques exceptions près comme le
souligne christophe drogue
il y aura toujours des minorités mais
ces minorités qu'on a qu'on voit en
temps ordinaire qui ont pas mal de
difficultés avec l'état de droit et de
ce côté là ça a l'air un petit peu de
continuer dans certains quartiers mais
l'immense majorité de la population a
l'air finale mode accepter pour le
moment ceux qui vont sur les marchés et
qui se battent pour aller chercher un
poids ou une tomate etc sans respecter
les est cela aussi son sont dangereux
pour les autres
on pense d'abord à soi c'est bien tout
le problème mais de l'époque de l'époque
alors conclusion je pense qu' il ne faut
pas désespérer d'ego lourd donc on va
pas se défausser ni sur un conseil
scientifique qui a été mis en place
seulement le 11 mars ni sur les français
qui serait soit disant très peu
obéissant non irresponsabilité elles
sont au pouvoir gouverner c'est prévoir
cette gestion de crise je pense que là
les lecteurs du figaro sont d'accord
avec moi elle est calamiteuse
alors vous qui est vectrice ou lecteurs
du figaro en tous les cas qui nous
regardaient sur le web
je vous invite à commenter je vous
invite à réagir je suis sûr que vous
avez une opinion sur ce que vous venez
d'entendre en tout cas à mon âge
[Musique]